citizens of the reject Nation I am just
walking out of Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol 3. this is my non-spoiler review and
I am in love I am back to feeling that
Marvel magic this is not only everything
I want from a Marvel movie this is
everything I want from a movie this is
everything I want from art that's made
me feel this was a magic trick where
James Gunn basically put me in a state
of all and then punctuated that awe with
Despair and joy so I was left with this
insane Whirlwind of just feeling it's
all the characters you love and being
reminded of why you love them it is
everything you want from the action
spectacle in that the action has weight
to it this felt so tangible especially
considering it is so bright and Cosmic
and allowed there are elements of this
that are so comic Booky this might be
the most comic bookie of my favorite
comic book films in that a lot of times
like you add a comic book Element and it
doesn't quite work for the medium of
comics this is insane there are
lovecraftian villains there are
chimera-esque villains there are
um fleshy organic planetoids there's so
much stuff that is pure Jim Sterling
Cosmic that somehow Works in this medium
and I and I cannot believe it exists
this well this balance and again that's
all because you trust in these
characters and your investment and your
love for these characters really makes
you able to be a part of any one of
these moments and be like yeah that
feels like it affects me yeah this is
something that I'm feeling and a lot of
that is obviously tied to the chemistry
of the Guardians but it's also tied into
the editing the the writing the
directing and here also ties to the
villain the villain here the high
evolutionary is a top tier comic villain
he's able to be both enormous like not
quite mustache twirly but big and bold
and loud and zod-ish but also
manipulative in a really contained way
there's a lot of elements of tiny
nuanced decisions that make you hate him
because of a contained
malignant move or or decision that it's
really interesting when juxtaposed with
a lot of the big swings and we've been
on this journey with the Guardians for a
long time and at the first film I
consider you know about a family and
then the second film obviously about
family and then the third film is about
found family the first film I'd say
mother second father third about self
and you just feel this connection
between all three films that is so
unique to any Trilogy this is easily my
favorite of the Marvel films as far as
trilogies go this is probably tied with
the first film I need to decide if the
first or this film is my favorite it is
definitely my favorite trilogy because
as I said this this is amongst my
favorite comic films of all time this is
either my top five or top three MCU
movies this thing is crazy I digress I'm
gonna I'm gonna break down some elements
for you so we've got the Duos right
we've got the gabora Star-Lord
relationship which I think is
fascinating and I think they do a really
good job and actually exceeded my
expectations that was one of the only
elements I was worried about was how
they'd handle that relationship and they
definitely maneuver between two extremes
and all the while you're really really
in love with hope and I think that's
exactly what this movie needed then
you've got the Mantis Drax relationship
which I think really really is an
interesting byproduct of having the
holiday special came out when it did
what that relationship is is not just
between them it's not just this
beautiful platonic relationship that I
think was really well written so it
doesn't become anything more it also
impacts the overall team in a really
interesting way in this film the team
Dynamic that comes from how drags and
mantis relate is really wonderful
especially in relating to Gamora you've
got rocket who will test the very limits
of what you think you can feel for an
animated creature special effects are
at a new level here especially with
emotional connection man that that
uncanny valley is broken and how much
you can feel and and the depths of which
you can believe in something that's ones
and zeros Bradley Cooper Take a Bow good
God and there's a really cool use of
timeline there there's a really cool use
of chronology and I love how jarring it
is and I think that's the only way this
movie works is by testing you by vexing
You by putting you through the ringer
emotionally because all these characters
are full of trauma including as ever one
of the MVPs of the entire MCU nebula she
is trauma incarnate her Arc has been
beautiful to see Karen Gillen is such a
force in nature as an actor like you can
put her in that position and have her
have that character and you can just
love this
black-eyed evil daughter of Thanos that
isn't evil that's overcome everything
that you think hates but Love's just so
impossibly deeply and that's so special
and then you've got Cosmo this dog we
want wanted to see in movies forever is
here and she is wonder she has magic and
then some new characters I don't want to
spoil anything of but uh Rockets lady is
everything you want to do from the
comics and all the characters in that uh
almost Toy Story two I think it's toy no
Toy Story one Toy Story one asks are
exactly what you want out of that scene
where you discover the origins of rocket
that he's kept so close to the vest for
all these years it's
these characters so that juxtaposed with
your hatred for high evolutionary that
mixed with the cosmic Wonder of what
this builds out to it is absolutely
stunning what they're able to accomplish
and then you've got the scale of it
right so the scope of the Marvel
universe is always a struggle basically
with Marvel you're always having to have
uh ever escalating like world ending
events but it doesn't always work
because basically if everything is an
Avengers level event nothing is an
Avengers level event right so this is
the first movie that to me feels like
Infinity War feels like end game feels
like Stakes feels like there's weight
but also that there's weight outside of
your team like obviously we don't live
in the MCU but it definitely feels like
there is something at stake that could
affect you not in as directive away as
you know I'm in harm but you want the
world to feel plausible and that
something could happen that could harm
you in some way and the way they build
the stakes here make it feel like that
could somehow impact you and that's
really special with a Guardians of the
Galaxy film uh let's talk about a couple
of the negatives the negative I had with
Adam Warlock definitely went away in the
beginning I didn't love the
characterization about a warlock
um actually feel like he was it's funny
actually it's it's kind of talking to
the comics in the beginning he feels
like when a writer doesn't know how to
write Adam Warlock but they do it on
purpose so the Adam Warlock
characterization is I think
intentionally misleading and then they
know him so well it writes itself it
does solve some of those elements so by
the time it lands I do really like Adam
Warlock I do really think that what they
have him end up like is worth that
initial maybe not so great of a decision
in the way he's introduced there's a an
expediency to it that bothers me still
but it's all juice worth the squeeze in
its situational uh awareness So Adam
Warlock is a slight negative another
negative I've heard is there's a bit of
whiplash in how the drama and comedy
goes back and forth I completely
patently disagree with that I think
that's what makes this movie special is
that Whiplash I completely disagree with
people think it's too dark and too full
of Despair that is what makes this movie
sing so people that are saying that
um
we had a different experience we'd
perform so those aren't negatives for me
uh I guess still negative I really have
is
man this is a damn near five-star film
um I think the biggest negative I
experienced was
I would have loved
I think
a little more you know I actually don't
have any
log I was gonna try to like make
something negative that wasn't just now
I'm trying to find a problem with this
movie I loved it it is so special it is
so what I needed it to be
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 one of my
favorite MCU films of all time one of my
favorite comic films of all time one is
actually shared films of all time James
Gunn is about to make the DC Universe
something truly Monumental because this
Trilogy is the best Trilogy in the MCU
and one of the best trilogies in film
and it sucked the landing and I'm so
happy thank you reject Nation please hit
the like hit that subscribe Bell please
do comment let me know what you guys
thought of the movie I tried to be as
spoiler free as possible I am very
curious about the discourse of this film
because I walked out of the theater
going like everyone's gonna love it who
can hate it apparently people I know and
trust so it is uh it's gonna be an
interesting discourse I adored it four
and a half maybe even five stars for me
got a lot of love for the Guardians a
lot of love for James Gunn a lot of love
for Comic fans getting that love back
love the movie talk to you guys soon
[Music]